i had a guy by the way that said the  following i can't you know this is a guy  that's  not a well-known guy but a known guy he  said no joke he said here's all i do  he said i have my phone and i get a  video  and i produce the video with them and i  say hi  i'm john doe  what's your name such and such  we  are you agreeing to do xyz with me yes  can you please say that are you okay do  you feel safe yes can i open a door  where you can live if you want to yes  you can leave if you want to i don't  want to do you want to leave i don't  want to leave you sure yeah okay let me  just give you toward the entire place  it's just me there's nobody else here  he's kind of going like this the second  video yeah and he said perfect thank you  and he files that for himself  in case this ever turns around complete  sense i tell you as weird as this sounds  yes